Romina ici qui est ce gars il est à toi
Je vais venir ici d'ici plus d'un
an vient d'enlever mon fils Je devrais être avec
lui Je n'étais pas avec mon père
regardé comme je me suis avéré comment tu vas
prendre soin de nous
je  Je ne peux pas penser à une autre ligne de travail dans
laquelle je préférerais être tu es si intelligent que
tu peux faire tout ce que tu veux je ne
comprends pas pourquoi tu fais ça mon flic
Jeff a un enfant que tu veux subvenir à
ça  gamin tu dois faire ça en utilisant tes
compétences tes compétences merde
Oh
cinq sur quatre tire sur
Thomas pour moi je suis toujours son père je peux
lui donner des trucs et je suis officier pour
regarder d'ici pour fouiller ta maison
jusqu'où  nous recherchons l'argent
que Luke Glanton vous a peut-être donné ou non
quelle subvention d'équipe la part du lion
passe par notre héros c'est
votre problème c'est notre problème puis-je le
porter à votre attention parce
que c'est ce que je devrais faire  Je veux que tu le fasses en
un jour Je ne te laisserai pas faire
descendre ce bateau Il y a un moyen
de s'en sortir  tu vas aimer ça
tu sais quelque chose regarde si tu roules comme l'
éclair tu vas t'écraser comme le
tonnerre